how's it going resumes Peter Pan welcome
to a brand new series about my hair just
[ __ ] kidding it's about video games
it's called who made this game and why
should just call all my videos that
first off we have undead Ryder a slim
it's made by scram game so that answered
the first so our question let's play it
says ride to the tube I'm this very
attractive woman man-child thing and I'm
going on in a tremendous view by the way
there we go this is a real man ride
their bike I'm dead end
ha you can't tell me I got all right
fine [ __ ] ah where am I going
what this looks na ho I died ha ha I
died again what happens then
no one knows [ __ ] right ok I think this
is how they taught me in driving school
um I am now a carousel how many times
you have to die to learn let's go here
[ __ ]
oh here it is feet on six feet under
there we go
oh here's the tomb no no no no now
cemetery gates
huh oh you [ __ ] kidding me you go
back there Bob bit man I'm not your mom
Bob all right nice and easy Bob nice and
he's set on the damn bike sit your ass
down son and - [ __ ] what am i doing
what is that
sucking on my titties [ __ ] you want
oh man it's phase four next right
there's more but where the hell is hell
Oh God not the skeletor's they hump me
stop don't molest me skeletor's I could
become a helicopter my bike left me aah
what does [ __ ] what is no not two
skeletons anything but didn't air don't
make out with me skeletons no yeah where
do I go
I I don't know where to go where the
hell is hell hello
Satan are you there please take me oh
that's not what I make yes Oh Oh Bobby's
back no no no nah Bob get the [ __ ] back
on the bike that's it Oh God Oh God ha
ha don't make out with him don't I don't
care how skinny they are those [ __ ]
sorry don't make out with him Bob are
you even trying what does it say I can't
I'm just gonna assume this no yes ha ha
ha ha oh my god oh there Satan deaf
you're here thank you for waiting
ah no no you're deadly clothes get it
hot Shh
damn it oh my god this game is so hard
I don't want to make out stop oh hello
no stop trying to be sexy Bob no one
thinks you're stuck okay maybe the
skeletons hey deaf my buddy how you
doing man
oh [ __ ] there's a tomb there's the tomb
I wish you were here
oh thanks man we did it we did it we n
tubed he's not dancing like last time I
think he's
solo all right last one probably
skeletons of society you can do it thank
you inspirational text are you [ __ ]
kidding me how the hell am I supposed to
do that
no texts in the world can get me through
that [ __ ] wall ride to hell yeah Wow you
did it thank you text thank you
I don't know who you are I'm gonna
assume you're Satan Thank You Satan oh
man Oh Satan what are you doing no no I
did not come this far Satan damn it stay
there Bob you stay there and you [ __ ]
the bike like we practice many times
let's ride you [ __ ] stay there
there's a tomb and tune [ __ ] yeah
you're not dancing anymore there we go
sucking on my titties lucky wallet when
I call away all that sugar mommy chipped
out my Sheba
honey what do you call that [ __ ] highway
to hell alright there we go this is what
I've been waiting for Oh God
Oh God chill out relax max and all :
I'll shoot some bar but not what come
down come down it's gonna be okay
don't don't I said don't Jesus Jesus is
not here that's for [ __ ] here ah know
what it's like they know what Bob you're
not a helicopter I've told you so many
times what what stop damn it
what all right we're fine we're fine I
just got to take a chill there we go hey
Dad how you doing man I missed ya [ __ ] I
think you're kind of [ __ ] Bob no never
never never never ever awful [ __ ] sake
the [ __ ] cars been really really what
a [ __ ] get up on the bike get the [ __ ]
up on the bike get the [ __ ] up on the
bike get the [ __ ] up on the bike get the
[ __ ] up on the bike
to [ __ ] up on the bike um they did it
what forget the [ __ ] bike you're cool
we're cool what the [ __ ] really
god damn it Bob that leg Bob I don't
know what to tell you you have great
flexibility all right thank God I mean
thank dad there's a tomb there's a tomb
we did it
we freaking did it Wow Dan suck us Dan's
I'm mother Dame's like Bob and now we're
gonna be sexy like that this game never
ends does it
oh god not you [ __ ] again I [ __ ]
hate you like I don't know what to tell
you
all right doing well just don't [ __ ]
this up like you'll lock are you kidding
me I don't even know where to go
not this way got it all right cool oh
god the skeletons made it here are you
kidding me go Bob hurry
oh God okay huh Oh God oh they're
everywhere
I bet huh babe then babe huh this is the
most intense moment of my Bab huh yes
I don't even know where we're going babe
but I know that I love you I love you
but that song I'm never gonna sing again
I'm sorry okay here we go
huh ha ha I don't know what the sign
says this way aah
Bob oh god no
now yes
we're okay we're okay I don't know what
highway yes Wow huh I don't know what's
going on I really really don't know
anything but yes but are we there I
can't see anything but I think we're
there I think what edit rusted past
all of me all the sexy [ __ ] down there
gonna be the greatest stripper of all
time just get a boob implant we did it
we did it
that's it I'm so proud of you and myself
mainly myself cuz I did all the work
bras brofist I mean like this video if
you enjoy watching I had a lot of fun
thing I think you bros enjoyed a little
of all I mean Halloween ll be our secret
stay our selves out